bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
émission encore confiné peut-être des
confiner le 11
à moins que ce soit le 18 ou peut-être
le 25
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des entreprises françaises face à
la crise bonjour estelle bonjour olivier
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouvel épisode de ses caches
focus aujourd'hui sur les entreprises
françaises comme angèle gère-t-elle
cette crise liée au corona à virus
comment envisage t elle l'avenir les
aides mises sur la table par le
gouvernement sont elles suffisantes ce
sont allés question à qui vont nous
occuper pour cela nous serons dans cette
émission avec nicolas de villiers
président du puy du fou et stefan mani
goal de la tête de quatre restaurants à
paris film est d'abord olivier un mot
sur la batterie de mesures déployées par
le gouvernement pour tenter de limiter
l'impact de cette crise économique liée
au qu'ovide 19 un plan de soutien à
hauteur de 110 milliards d'euros contre
45 initialement prévue à la mi mars a
été déployé alors sur ses 110 milliards
24 environ sont consacrés aux
dispositifs de chômage partiel je
rappelle qu'aujourd'hui cela concerne
890 milles entreprises et 11,3 millions
de salariés et 7 milliards c'est la
dotation du fonds de solidarité destiné
aux entreprises dont le chiffre
d'affaires est inférieur à 1 million
d'euros et qui sont victimes d'une perte
d'activité de plus de 50% ces deux
derniers mois
l'aide accordée et 2500 euros par mois
et peut aller jusqu'à 5000 euros pour
les restaurants les hôtels ou plus
largement les entreprises liées au
secteur du tourisme
le montant de l'aide est porté à dix
mille euros le gouvernement aussi donner
la possibilité aux entreprises dans le
besoin de reporter à les cotisations
sociales et les impôts directs
à noter aussi cette enveloppe de 300
milliards d'euros pour garantir tous les
nouveaux prêts que les entreprises
solliciterait auprès de leur banque
olivier un mot votre avis sur ces
mesures sont-elles suffisantes
absolument pas donc ça n'empêchera pas
les saillies ça c'est une chose
d'autant plus que on sait absolument pas
quand le quoi le confinement va se
terminer
donc vous doutez bien que
des restaurants des sociétés
d'événementiel des indépendants vont
mettre la clé sous la porte
quelles que soient les aides qui leur
seront accordés ensuite c'est je dirais
c'est facile d'annoncer 300 milliards
passé de 47 à 100 et c'est toute façon c
c'est toujours la même chose c'est de
l'impôt futur
donc attendez-vous à des hausses
exceptionnelles d'impôts on va avoir
d'ici la fin de l'année un impôt de
solidarité sur le go vide et qui ne sera
pas réservé aux ultras riches ou aux
riches qui sera sur toute la classe
moyenne
parce que faudra payer l'addition alors
c'est facile si vous voulez de
distribuer l'argent des autres 1 c c'est
un sport que les politiques connaissent
et est ici emploi avec avec une une
légèreté coupable alors olivier on va
continuer d'évoquer la situation des
entreprises françaises avec un exemple
concret nous sommes en liaison avec
stéphane manigold président du groupe
éclore bonjour monsieur manigold bien
menée dans ces caches merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté de répondre à nos
questions alors au fond jaune vous
possédez quatre restaurants à paris aux
établissements sont donc fermés depuis
le 14 mars dernier récemment jacques
baly le président du guide gault et
millau a estimé que 25 % des restaurants
étaient menacés de fermeture définitive
vous comment est ce que vous vivez cette
crise
j'ai payé à raison mais on va rentrer
dans le détail parce que la réponse en
réalité elle est plurielle
si vous prenez les grandes métropoles
type e lyon marseille paris
on va être hélas bien au delà de ces
chiffres je pense qu'on va plutôt être
entre 40 voire comme nos amis
new-yorkais 50% de fermeture la réalité
c'est que le gouvernement a mis en place
des mesures de sauvegarde notamment de
me salariés et ça c'est une bonne chose
ce qui nous permet de ne pas licencier
mais la casse derrière si l'économie ne
repart pas si la confiance ne repart pas
elle va être terrible alors la confiance
elle passe par quoi elle passe par tout
simplement un traitement un vaccin et
tous les gestes barrières que l'on peut
nous demander dans le cadre d'une
ouverture ne leur donnerons pas la
confiance et la casse et des terribles
puisque nous depuis le 14 mars
00h01 nous rentrons 000 centimes de
chiffre d'affaires pour autant nous
avons des charges fixes qui s'appelle un
loyer qui s'appelle l'électricité le gaz
tout ça continue à courir et nous
continuons à honorer nos charges
alors notre groupe est plutôt plutôt
solide donc on n'a pour le moment pas de
difficultés mais je reste assez
pessimiste quant à une ouverture
prochaine veillée olivier delamarche
vous décrivez comme kaka d'économistes
pessimiste moi je pense que nous les
restaurateurs on ne verra pas avant fin
août
il faut être fou est en tout cas à paris
ou dans les grandes villes
pourquoi parce qu'on voit le
développement du virus il a démarré dans
un grand test notamment à toulouse et
paris est lourdement en outre touché par
par ce virus donc économiquement on va
pas réouvrir demain soyons soyons clair
aux mots monsieur m'a dit gueule sur ce
plan d'eau
de sauvetage en mise en place par le
gouvernement olivier estimé que ces
mesures n'étaient pas suffisantes ou
vous quel est votre avis alors il a
raison et je veux rajouter un point
c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'ensemble de mon
groupe vit grâce à l'argent public et
c'est parfaitement insupportable et je
veux dire pourquoi parce que nous avons
des contrats de droit privé qui
s'appelle à une assurance qui pallierait
cette perte d'exploitation et
aujourd'hui nous avons nous pour notre
part était obligé au même titre que de
nombreux restaurateurs de faire valoir
nos droits devant des tribunaux
notamment un tribunal de commerce de
paris
donc je suis confiant sur le sujet et je
rêve vous voyez chers olivier de rendre
cet argent public les femmes verse pour
que les contrats de droit privé puisse à
s'appliquer
vous prenez l'histoire des assureurs dia
à peu près un mois que nous ont tous dit
en fanfare y compris la fédération
française des assurances circulez ya
rien à voir
il n'ya pas contraint le risque
systémique et tous les nouveaux mots qui
nous ont mis dans la tête pandémie in
assurabilité côté sérielle en réalité un
mois après le masque tombe et on voit
bien que au sein de la fédération
française des assurances vous avez trois
blogs vous avez un premier blog qui est
les mutualistes
vous avez ensuite un deuxième bloc qui
est les banques assurances et vous avez
un troisième bloc assez traditionnel qui
s'appelle les assurances traditionnel
deux blocs ont lâché les mutualistes ont
décidé d'indemniser ce au titre
contractuels soit au titre de la
solidarité les banques derrière
assurances ont suivi et reste
aujourd'hui des réfractaires qui eux
disparaîtront aussi ils ne font rien qui
s'appelle les assurances traditionnelle
qui non seulement se soustraire à
l'obligation contractuelle mais cerise
sur le gâteau et c'est là où c'est
ironique c'est qu'aujourd'hui dénonce le
crédit mutuel en disant mais vous avez
des engagements contractuels et vous
devez les respecter et qu'en réalité
votre solidarité
il n'en est rien c'est simplement pour
vous soustraire à vos obligations
alors ça c'est de l'argent aujourd'hui
public qui nous est distribué alors que
les assureurs devraient
couvrir ses parts d'exploitation alors
justement olivier une réaction à ce que
vient de dire monsieur manigat au sujet
des assureurs ans qui refuse
d'indemniser à les entreprises parce que
les assureurs sont mal et est donc ils
savent très bien que six semaines à
indemniser ils vont sauter donc et il
sait exactement le même problème pour
pour beaucoup de sociétés
regardez ce qui se passe avec air france
air france indemnise les américains et
les israéliens parce qu'ils les ont
menacés de de class action donc d'action
de regrouper et et on donne bbb bon pour
qui valable un an pour rembourser les
français parce que on sait qu' il y aura
pas trop de casse
parce qu'ils ne feront que des actions
individuelles donc ça c'est c'est
l'assurance
c'est probablement le même le même
principe
c'est à dire que quand on on efface
peut-être à des syndicats de
restaurateurs
là ils vont ils vont finir par payer
quand vous aurez des indépendants et b
et des particuliers là ils paieront pas
parce que ils vous diront de vous
asseoir dessus parce que parce qu'ils
savent qu'ils sont pas ils sont pas dans
une position extraordinaire avec la
récession qui arrivent les les assureurs
et les réassureurs pourrait être obligé
de payer des montants ahurissant si vous
permettez à des rentrées dans les
chiffres il faut distinguer deux choses
les engagements contractuels et
l'intégralité des pertes d'exploitation
si effectivement demain les assureurs
devaient prendre l'intégralité des
pertes d'exploitation sur trois mois on
parle de 60 milliards
ça c'est l'intégralité des pertes
d'exploitation est il dans un pathos
absolue nous explique louis iv on peut
pas très bien entre 0 et 60 milliards il
ya des chiffres il y en a plein
d'ailleurs il suffit il faudrait plein
de vie pour compter jusqu'à 60 milliards
et la réalité c'est que axa par exemple
sur ses engagements contractuels est
exposé à 3 milliards
oui on encore loin des 60 milliards de
la perte d'exploitation et 60 milliards
il se trouve aussi par extraordinaire
que c'est le montant total des fonds
propres de l'ensemble des assureurs
louis et 3 milliards on n'a pas encore
mis le système par terre ça c'est ce
qu'ils essaient de dire deuxièmement si
on cumule l'intégralité des engagements
contractuels puisque la ffa a fini à
force de la repousser la présidente a
fini par donner un chiffre
il faut savoir qu'il ya trois millions
de 102 millions 300 mille contrats
d'assurance multiples multirisque
professionnelle et demi son marché elle
a fini du bout des lèvres de dire mais
en réalité il ya 10% des contrats qui
sont concernés par ces pertes
d'exploitation contractuellement je le
dis bien donc 10 % de 60 minerve en
perte d'exploitation n'arrive à 6
milliards
donc on n'a pas mis le rize leleu les
assureurs par terre ils ont juste les
respecter leurs engagements contractuels
alors monsieur manigold un un dernier
mot avant avant de se quitter à la
réouverture des bars et restaurants sera
statué fin mai vous vous prévoyez une
réouverture en août pour autant vous
quel comment est ce que vous envisagez
concrètement cette réouverture comment
est-ce qu'on vous envisager l'avenir
en réalité une ouverture précipiter
c'est à dire sans confiance du
consommateur avec des entreprises qui
ont des fonds propres a
zéro voire négatif ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire une ouverture une masse
salariale des charges qui reviennent
dans l'entreprise peu de chiffres
d'affaires ou pas fin du mois je peux
vous garantir qu'il ya une case terrible
soit il ya une réelle
c'est d'ailleurs c'est pas au
restaurateur de décider ou aux
politiques ou aux obtenez de décider si
c'est dangereux ou pas je crois qu'on se
trompe de sujet c'est bien comité
scientifique de se prononcer sur le
sujet moi je sais mettre en place des
normes haccp qui sont des normes
d'hygiène qui vous évite d'avoir
quelques contrariétés sur quelques jours
et moins mettre des normes qui empêche
un virus de tuer je sais pas faire il y
a des virologues qui ont 13 ans d'études
derrière eux 20 ans ou 30 ans de
pratique ils ont toujours pas trouvé un
remède
alors moi en tant que restaurateur je
répète je suis ni médecin ni
scientifique ni chercheurs je ne vois
pas comment nous arriverons à faire face
à ce virus qui tue merci à beaucoup
stéphane manigold avoir été parmi nous
je rappelle que vous êtes président du
groupe éclore propriétaire de quatre
restaurants à paris olivier avant de
recevoir notre deuxième invités ont
marqué une courte pause et on se
retrouve dans un instant bienvenue dans
ces caches si vous nous rejoignez les
entreprises face à la crise c'est le
thème de cette émission et pour en
parler olivier cette fois nous sommes en
liaison avec nicolas de villiers
président du puy-du-fou bonjour monsieur
de villiers
merci merci beaucoup à d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
monsieur deviner quelle est la situation
du puy du fou aujourd'hui vaincu du foot
tourne au ralenti parce que nous sommes
fermés le parquet est fermée
naturellement tous nos spectacles sont à
l'arrêt actuellement et nous discutons
quotidiennement avec les services de
l'état pour essayer de savoir si bien
ils ont connaissance déjà des mesures
par exemple de sécurité sanitaire qui
seront nécessaires à la réouverture
si on peut nous proposer une date aussi
de réouverture dès aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas encore de réponse claire
il ya une légère avance et on peut le
dire avec l'intervention du premier
ministre qui semble commencer à donner
un cadre
même si
le préfet du département dont nous
dépendons ne le disais tout à l'heure
et bien il y à des rassemblements
interdits au delà de 10 personnes et
puis ensuite il ya des rassemblements
interdits au delà de 5000 personnes mais
entre les deux on sait pas très bien
c'est un peu le flou donc je vous avoue
que je me réjouis que les choses
avancent et que l'état commence à donner
les chiffres et quelques idées de date
mais en même temps nous sommes encore
dans le flou votre le parc du puy-du-fou
devrait devait rouvrir début avril
à combien s'élève aujourd'hui votre
manque à gagner vous savez aujourd'hui
on perd près d'un million d'euros par
jour et on peut considérer que non
seulement avril mais aussi le mois de
mai sont désormais certains d'être fermé
donc c'est près de 50 millions d'euros
qu'on a perdu ans et deux mois
nous sommes une activité saisonnière et
donc notre chiffre d'affaires se fait
sur à peu près sept mois de l'année et
vous imaginez l'impact lorsque nous
perdons un mois c'est de l'ordre de 20%
quand c'est le mois d'avril qui est un
excellent mois en général et c'est
valable autant pour le puy du fou pour
le tourisme de façon générale alors
lisez vous avez une question pour
monsieur de villiers oui bonjour je
voulais
savoir si si on en fait en privé quand
vous êtes en face d'eux des services de
l'état ils ont une idée un petit peu
plus précise que ce qu'ils nous disent à
la télé parce que franchement moi le
discours de monsieur edouard philippe
je suis resté sur ma faim j'ai pas
encore compris c'est là c'est la
politique du en même temps j'ai pas
encore compris très bien quand est ce
que vous pourriez ouvrir c'est vrai que
j'ai la chance de parler au président la
république et notamment vendredi matin
lors d'une conférence téléphonique qu'il
avait organisée pour l'ensemble des
acteurs du tourisme et surtout les
restaurateurs les hôteliers
même s'ils sont des domaines d'action a
finalement assez différent ils ont en
commun d'être des lieux de retrouvailles
pour les français j'ai eu le sentiment
que le chef de l'état nous écoutait et
non seulement ça mais moi j'ai proposé
le 2 juin comme date d'ouverture des
sites de loisirs comme le puy du fou et
je vois que le premier a repris la date
du 2 juin est ce que c'est suite à notre
proposition je ne sais pas ce que je
sais c'est que j'ai le sentiment que
l'état écoute beaucoup et que en
particules chef de l'état cherche à à
ceux à capter un maximum d'informations
de la part des acteurs économiques dans
tous les secteurs confondus et notamment
notre secteur cela étant honnêtement
après avoir des discussions avec des
délégués interministérielle avec
quelques ministres également et avec un
certain nombre de hauts fonctionnaires
j'ai un peu le sentiment d'un léger
manque de coordination au sein du
gouvernement c'est à dire qu'on a un
chef de l'état qui essaye d'avoir une
vision claire des choses mais ensuite la
machine de l'état est en fait le
gouvernement suit avec un peu de
difficulté à se coordonner
je vous dis les choses comme je les
ressens un sens façon très nette et et
surtout sans langue de bois parce que
moi je suis entrepreneur et je vous dis
les choses comme je les ressens après
vous dire que je peux sentir dans ce
qu'ils me disent des certitudes quant à
la reprise du virus comme vous le disiez
non je crois qu'ils sont dans une
incertitude totale je peux le comprendre
je sais que beaucoup de français
aimeraient que l'état prenne des
décisions plus clair je le comprends
aussi et je suis dans certainement dans
ceux qui aimeraient avoir des décisions
plus clair mais je pense sincèrement
qu'ils ne savent pas vraiment estimé si
le virus va repartir après la crise ils
ont en tout cas très clairement dit le
chef de l'état l'a dit clairement que
ils craignent que le virus reprennent de
l'élan lorsque le déconfinement aura
lieu messieurs dvd vous perdez aussi
pour la création d'un fonds de
compensation pour les professionnels du
tourisme
oui absolument parce que oui pardon je
vous coupe mais oui absolument l'idée
c'est que notre activité est saisonnière
comme l'a dit au lieu de la marche c'est
à dire que nous avons une perte de
chiffre d'affaires qui est fatal est
irrattrapable
à partir du moment où nous sommes fermés
par exemple au mois d'avril au mois de
mai donc pour mes biens et permettre à
ces entreprises de survivre les comme le
puy du fou par exemple qui est à la
capitale associatif car nous ne sommes
adossés ni à la puissance publique n'a
une puissance financière donc n'avons
pas de magot caché dans une arrière
cuisine offshore donc il nous faut
pouvoir rebondir pouvoir relancer
l'activité mais surtout pouvoir survivre
donc je vais proposer une subvention
exceptionnelle pour un site comme le puy
du fou nous sommes bien placés pour le
demander puisque ça fait 42 ans que nous
existons ça fait 42 ans que ne manquent
jamais touché de subventions pour la
première fois nous demandons une aide de
l'état exceptionnels pour l'ensemble des
500 sites de loisirs qui sont rassemblés
dans un syndicat national et c'est une
aide qui est moins 200 millions d'euros
pour l'ensemble des sites en france donc
c'est pas considérable quand on voit les
aides que l'état apporté par ailleurs a
beaucoup de secteurs économiques
et quand on sait que le tourisme qui
pourraient être sauvées donc pour moins
de 200 millions d'euros rapporte 8 % du
pib national
olivier c'est une bonne idée à la
création d'un fonds de compensation au
combat il faut voir comment ça va être
non seulement constitué et en plus après
distribués mais en effet si c'est une
histoire de 200 millions d'euros
c'est pas une c'est intéressant de le
faire parce que comme le disait nicolas
vous avez le tourisme est une des forces
de la france et que donc il faut pas que
ces entreprises coulent
donc si c'est une histoire de 200
millions d'euros c'est c'est forcément
quelque chose d'intéressant
non moi ce qui me ce qui m'inquiète
c'est que si vous voulez encore une fois
on gère cette crise qu'avec de la dette
donc avec de l'impôt futur
là on distribue à tour de bras
100 milliards par ci 300 milliards par
là alors qu'on voit que la france
sixième puissance du monde est pas
capable de nids de tester les français
ni de leur fournir de quoi se protéger
et qu'on résout exactement comme comme
les autres pas comme beaucoup d'autres
le truc en laissant en laissant les
choses se faire et on bloquant
complètement le l'économie française est
ensuite basse pas grave on fait on fait
de la dette et on fait tourner la
planche à billets alors monsieur d
justement les mesures de déconfinement
annoncée par le premier ministre le 28
avril dernier
selon vous sont elles compatibles avec
une reprise de l'activité économique
comment on fait cohabiter reprise
économique et sécurité sanitaire comment
vous voyez les choses pour le puy du fou
ben c'est très simple nous le puy du fou
comme l'ensemble des sites de loisirs
français professionnels nous sommes des
professionnels du flux ça veut dire que
nous sommes des professionnels depuis
des décennies de la circulation des
personnes
donc lorsqu'on déconfite le 11 mai
prochain si l'objectif est tenu une rue
parisienne devient un espace public
accessible gratuitement mais désordonnée
quand un site comme le puy du fou est un
espace public payant mais organisé par
des professionnels donc on ne voit pas
pourquoi le métro qui restait ouvert
pendant cette crise où la rue parisienne
qui vous sera bondée un soir d'été après
le déconfinement serait accessible au
public alors qu'elle n'est pas organisé
un justement une pensée de gestion du
flux étant que caen tandis que le plus
fou serait fermée alors que justement
nous sommes des professionnels de la
gestion de ces flux de personnes
nous savons organiser les allées de nos
sites pour que sur les plus de 100
hectares à ciel ouvert en plein air et
bien nos spectateurs puissent ne jamais
se mélanger les uns aux autres que les
fruits ne se croise pas qu'ils puissent
avoir accès à une restauration adaptée à
la crise bref que nous puissions
respecter l'ensemble des mesures
sanitaires qui sont préconisées au delà
des gestes-barrières par l'état donc je
crois que ça serait un non sens de
laisser fermer le puy du fou quand on
ouvre les rues parisiennes ou le métro
ou même les grandes surfaces qui sont
des lieux beaucoup plus dangereux sur le
plan sanitaire que nos les incite
organisé par les professeurs que nous
sommes
voyez vous êtes d'accord c'est un non
sens
cette histoire de baisser les rues
accessible et fermé les parcs de loisirs
c'est un non sens de laisser le métro
fonctionne et parce que il n'ya pas pire
c'est un non sens de faire rentrer des
élèves dans des classes à partir du 11
mai mais deux de ne pas réouvrir
d'autres d'autres endroits on voit que
c'est pas c'est pas gérer cette histoire
depuis le départ
malheureusement on est en train de le
payer lourdement et et des activités
comme le puy du fou le paye beaucoup
plus que que notre donc on n'a aucune
cohérence on n'a aucune cohérence dans
les mesures on n'a aucune cohérence dans
les discours
vous avez un président qui dit quelque
chose le lendemain le ministre dément
quand il ya de la croissance tout va
bien je veux dire n'importe qui peut
gérer les choses quand ça se passe mal
on tient un gros accident c'est
compliqué d'avoir des gens qui sont pas
au niveau
un dernier mot à nicolas deviner avant
de se quitter
est-ce qu'en plus des pertes subies déjà
avec ce début de saison manqué vous
craignez que les gens ne soient pas au
rendez vous aussi réouverture il ya tout
dépend de la communication de l'état ça
veut dire que si l'état continue à avoir
une communication extrêmement anxiogène
il est évident notre et quant à sion va
en pâtir la fréquentation c'était le
nombre de visiteurs qui vont venir nous
voir
ce sera évidemment inférieurs à la
moyenne et a l'habitude mais il faut je
crois que l'état est une communication
positive même si il faut dire la vérité
sur les dangers de ce virus
ça va de soi donc nous nous attendons à
effectivement une saison très sinistré
avec un nombre de visiteurs forcément en
baisse par rapport à l'habitude c'est
certain il serait fou de penser l
inverse mais on peut tout à fait le
comprendre et il y à des visiteurs qui
voudront rester prudent et on le
comprend tout à fait s'il ya beaucoup à
nicolas devilliers d'avoir insulté par
mino dans cette émission je n'appelle
que vous êtes le président du puy du fou
olivier c'est l'heure des questions cash
vous le savez dorénavant vous pouvez
poser toutes vos questions à olivier
delamarche sur les réseaux sociaux avec
le hashtag rtk chili répondra dans cette
émission si votre question est
sélectionné alors cette semaine olivier
biscuits bonjour pensez vous que changer
ses oraux en dollar ou au yen est un
moyen de préserver son capital financier
et coûté en tout cas diversifiée et ne
pas rester à 100 % en euros oui moi le
yen s'est pas ma tasse de thé parce que
hui ce qu'ils ont fait avec leurs leur
banque centrale je suis pas sûr que ça
reste une monnaie de réserve
en revanche le dollar est toujours une
monnaie de réserve même si beaucoup de
pays et 7 sort sans qu'on passait ça
reste l'actif le plus liquide donc pour
l'instant je préfère le dollar à l'euro
on passe à la question à d'heureux qui
brûlent olivier à quand le changement de
monnaie pour les échanges internationaux
pour l'instant ce que je sais ça recoupe
la première question quand je vous
disais que le dollar restait tout de
même
l'actif le plus liquide au monde et que
donc
était encore là monnaies mondiales
maintenant oui beaucoup de pays
cherchent à s'en passer
la russie la chine et serra et donc ils
sont peut-être en train de nous préparer
la prochaine monnaies mondiales mais
pour l'instant elle n'est pas encore
sortie
la date de sortie demandé aux chinois
question de méthane à d'olivier des
impôts à la clé oui mais lesquels sur
quoi exactement jusqu'où peut aller le
gouvernement pour payer la dette
alors attendez là je vais sortir ma
boule de cristal j'en sais fichtre rien
et figurez vous monsieur macron n'a pas
ma ligne directe enfin où il l'a
peut-être mais en tout cas ils
m'appellent pas pour me demander ce que
j'en pense donc ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que vous aurez évidemment des
augmentations d'impôts que ça ne
m'étonnerai absolument pas que vous ayez
un impôt sur le type isf si vous voulez
mais avec un seuil abaissé qui fera que
le le le ménage moyen paiera en fonction
de son patrimoine d'ici la fin de
l'année ça serait absolument pas
étonnant et monsieur darmana un beau
dire le contraire c'est un menteur merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivie pour voir ou
revoir nos précédents numéros rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt feront ce point être tv n'oubliez pas
de poser toutes vos questions à olivier
delamarche en commentaire de ces vidéos
olivier le dernier mois bien écoutez je
crains que malheureusement pour la
prochaine émission nous ne puissions pas
aller au restaurant après